hello everyone I just got back from the
gym and I thought what better time to
make my daily video then now this next
game is a suggestion from a subscriber
and mr. chief and 24 said you can do
that game between Grand Master yang
Gustavson and Magnus Carlsen and he said
the funny thing is that Magnus Carlsen
was playing on his friend's account and
obviously I had no idea what he was
talking about but I thought if this is
true then this is some devious prank
indeed but I just googled constant
versus Gustav's on a friend's account
and immediately almighty Google delivers
on the first result it's actually it's
actually the account from cousin's
friend Norwegian Grandmaster Johann
Salomon and I know the guy I follow him
on Twitter we played a couple of games
on leeches so I will put a link to his
Twitter account in the description below
if you if you like you know daily chess
content which you probably do since
you're here you can also check out his
content he posts a lot of chess related
stuff and a ton of puzzles I mean a lot
of puzzles so if you enjoy puzzles and
you know the chests in general feel free
to follow him so back to the game it was
played on during one of young Gustavson
banter blitz sessions on chess 24-hour
young accepts challenges from chess 24
premium users and a new challenger
emerged and it was Grandmaster Johan
Salomon or so it said and Yun said that
he already lost one game to Johan
Solomon I don't know when that first
game was played so this seems like a
good opportunity for him to get to get
his revenge and the game started but
little did good stuff so know that it
was actually Magnus Carlsen playing
again against him on that account so
knife to f3 by Gustav Sun and f5 and
already on says here that although
solomon crushed him in the previous game
now he wants to humiliate him by playing
the dutch g3 Knight to f6 Bishop - g - e
6y on castles Carlsen Bishop e7 c4
we have castles and Knight to c3 g6 and
d4 and now we have it the Dodge defends
the fianchetto classical variation a 5 B
3 now Queen to e8 and here Gustafson
said this is this is still standard
theory that he never really studied this
because he just doesn't like it for
black but he probably should
Bishop to 83 we have night 286 now
Carlson is preparing to jump to be four
rook the C one night to be four now and
the Queen to d2 we have 92 before
attacking the Queen Knight captures F
captures on e4 kicking the knight from F
391 and now Queen to g6 defending the e4
pawn Knight to c2 and we have Bishop to
g5 now attacking the Queen and the rook
so III was played by yon not 93 is also
an option but III isn't isn't you know
any worse so III 93 now Carson
immediately seizes the opportunity to to
jump on d3 Roxy 31 as the rook was
attacked and E 5 now and E 5 isn't
actually the best move here probably
something like b6 or Bishop to d7
followed by c6 and you know it's it's an
okay game for white and black but II 5
is actually not the best move and here
yang took like one minute and it's a
boy's game five minutes each no
increment you can't really afford to
spend too much time and here young
captured Bishop captures on e4 over
ideas of Queen captures and then
capturing the knight would the Queen but
what he actually had and he was thinking
of playing this move was d captures on
e5 but to actually calculate a variation
like this in a blitz game is I don't
know C it seems impossible yeah you have
to play D captures on e5 and then after
Bishop to g4 attacking the rook you have
to find this Bishop captures on e4 and
after Queen captures on e4 now Queen
captures on d3 now black can't grab the
rook since the queen is attacked and
for Queen captures rook captures and now
after Bishop to e2 yes your rooks do get
pinned and maybe Gustavson was
calculating it and he reached this
position and he thought now okay this
doesn't work but actually after rook to
d5 sure you do lose the exchange of
Bishop captures on f1 keen captures on
f1 rook to a5 now h4 kicking the Bishop
Bishop e7 and f4 you actually have so
much compensation for the exchange
you're up you're up two pawns this is
actually a much better position for
white ephors coming you're ready to put
the pawns the King can support the
knight can jump into the game with some
nice squares for it later like he can
never capture the bishop on e7 would be
hanging so a lot a lot compensation for
the exchange but okay it's a blitz game
after e5 Bishop captures on e4 Queen
captures on e4 and Queen captures on b3
now Queen to f3 by Carlsen D captures on
e5 Bishop to f5 now attacking the Queen
and another critical moment in the game
here young lady for but instead there
was again a much better move Knight to
d4 now attacking the Queen and the
bishop and after Bishop captures and
Knight captures yes you do give up the
rook Bishop captures on f1 but after
Knight captures on g5 now your Bishop is
attacked on f1 there should be two rook
to d2 kicking the bishop back Bishop Age
5
now each actor son b6 c capture son d6
and Knight to e4
again winning this pawn and after
something like to f3 you capture and
again you have three points for the
exchange so three points for the
exchanges quite a lot that's probably
winning for white but okay again it's a
blitz game after Bishop f5 Gustavson
plate efore and here it's all all Magnus
now queen capture son b3 rook captures
on d3 now better captures on e4
attacking the rook and the knight rope
the c3 now comes the bishop to d2 again
attacking the rook the rook the
really have anywhere to go okay rook to
e3 was played Bishop captures on c2
grabbing the piece but Yun thought he
would get the piece back with rook to e2
but now when he saw Bishop to b4 he said
he was like wow what is this sorcery he
didn't saw that after Bishop captures on
before Bishop to d3
since the rook and he's losing one of
the rooks and in this position he
decided to resign the game and he said I
don't know what what you're doing over
there mr. Solomon but it's like you're
something like it's like you're the
greatest genius in the world and it was
very hard for him to play this game he
came almost down to one minute you know
not not even knowing he was playing
against Magnus Carlsen the world
champion but yeah I won't put a link in
the description below where you can
watch the original video and you can
really you know it's it's really
something else when you see on his
expression when he plays this game but
like I said after a bishop captures
Bishop to d3 was played in this position
he resigned you don't really have
anything here after you play something
like rook e1 better captures if you
capture the bishop Carson captures the
bishop on b4 if you just move it Bishop
f3 you're down a piece and I'm here down
a rook and no point in continuing this
game so yeah a wonderful game and quite
a devious prank on young Gustavson maybe
maybe it's due to the fact I don't know
that I remember after round 1 of Magnus
Carlsen versus Sergey Carrick in the
last year in December young Gustafson
had that very nice roasting video
towards Magnus Carlsen and you know I
mean I'm sure Carlsen wasn't offended
but maybe it had something to do with
this who knows so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank John chin anonymous person and
Timothy our butter for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it and I would like to thank
everyone for a contribution via bitcoin
and litecoin since I don't get an like a
notification who sent it I don't have
proper means of thanking you but thank
you all I also really appreciate it
you know it's just the same so yeah as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon